and our shutout tonight is for someone
who is not a journalist but who's a
building to come up with some major
stories has got big news organizations
begging him to tell them how he did it
it was in the middle of a blizzard
Washington DC when Seamus Hughes scored
one of his many big scoops this year it
was a snowy day my kids are playing the
front yard they were building a snowman
and I needed a break from cleaning off
the car and for fun Hughes is the kind
of person who likes to look at a website
called pacer that records the activities
of federal criminal courts around the
country documents have been posted on
pacer in Maryland that day and came
across it what he came across was the
indictment of a member of the US Coast
Guard who had purchased a huge quantity
of weapons and authorities say was about
to use them to carry out a mass murder
we just tweeted it out and then by the
time the Snowman was was done we had
about 10,000 retweets on it it was a
huge story that made headlines across
the country investigators say he was
planning a major attack on innocent
civilians they say they found at least
15 guns and 1000 rounds of ammunition
prosecutors are calling him a domestic
terrorist a story that might have gone
unnoticed by other journalists but for
Seamus Hughes and he used the same
sleuthing technique to break the story
of the government's indictment of
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange I was
looking at a case in Virginia of a guy
who was supporting terrorism and the
prosecutor that case accidentally filed
information related to Julian Assange so
entirely serendipitous entirely
serendipitous founder Julian Assange in
an unsealed court filing suggesting he
might be criminally charged WikiLeaks
founder Julian Assange has been charged
under seal another major story for which
the country's leading journalist ODE
Hughes a giant thank you I think there's
there's two things going on right one is
a lack of training when it comes to open
source collection and looking at at
court records and the other thing is
chasing the news of the day you know the
late the latest presidential tweet
get you more clicks than a deep dive in
a Coast Guard individual who was
thinking about joining neo nazism and so
that's you go in areas where nobody else
is really uh
farming yeah I think that's that's fair
there's no in farming and we're also
losing a lot of journalists in the last
couple years as the industry constraints
and so you're not having the same I used
to have on there these local newspapers
don't have federal court reporters
sitting at the courthouse
pulling stuff obsessive document digger
and it has brought Hughes a lot of
attention with profiles on CBS news and
elsewhere Hughes isn't really even a
journalist he works at George Washington
University's terror tracking section a
former US government official who worked
in the National Counterterrorism Center
so now he's busy teaching actual
journalists how to do their jobs better
I've done about trainings for about
2,000 journalists in the last four
months New York Times Washington Post
ABC CBS Associated Press basically
teaching them the tricks of the trade it
all began as Hugh's work to track young
Americans who have been recruited by
Isis in al-qaeda
he says the threat from those groups is
far from over of as much concern to
Hughes is the spike in what can be
called domestic terrorism linked to
groups overseas I'm not sure the media's
really picked up the transnational
nature of domestic terrorism and so it's
not necessarily domestic terrorism it's
also international and you see these
white supremacist groups have links to
organizations in Europe and in Australia
New Zealand and I think it's going to be
a learning curve in the short term
there's also you have to think of we've
had you know nearly 20 years of
understanding groups like al Qaeda and
Isis ideology and understanding the
white supremacists and even sovereign
citizen ideology is a different animal
and so there's gonna be a learning curve
why do you do it if you give me a piece
of information and tell me you know I've
got two days to figure it out I'm gonna
roll up my sleeves make some phone calls
get on a plane and start talking to
people because that's the only way
you're gonna figure it out well thank
you so much keep up the good work
and so a very big shout-out to Seamus
Hughes who's taught a lot of journalists
include
this one how to do their jobs much
better well that's our program for
tonight thanks for joining us we'll see
you back here next week